[Music]
marvel's latest disney plus original
series the falcon and the winter soldier
has taken viewers on an action-packed
thrill ride full of twists and turns
and now there's only one episode left
here's the ending of the falcon and the
winter soldiers penultimate episode
truth explained in response to the
brutal
public murder he committed last week
john walker is stripped of his shield
and the captain america title in the
opening sequence of truth
he engages sam and bucky in a brutal
fist fight
from which the two avengers narrowly
walk away while walker rips
sam's falcon wings off sam still walks
away from the battle with the bloody
captain america shield in hand
after facing that humiliating loss the
now injured walker then has to stand
before the u.s government
and learn he's no longer captain america
and has lost
all of his military honors and
privileges understandably crushed by
this verdict walker takes some time to
reflect
and then he's approached by a mysterious
woman she introduces herself as
contessa valentina allegra de fontaine
otherwise known as madame hydra in the
pages of marvel comics
and explains to walker that she can turn
his luck around
she leaves him with a seemingly blank
business card before departing
telling him to take her call when the
time comes the next time walker appears
on screen is for the episode's
post-credits sequence
the series first so far in which he's
shown constructing a brand new shield
for himself
i am captain america
at this point it's apparent that walker
is headed into us
agent territory just as he does in the
comics
what role val and or the organization
she represents
will play in the story going forward
remains a mystery
is hydra back is this version of the
character
representing a new different bunch of
baddies in the mcu
after making a quick escape from the
dora melange last week
baron zemo visits his home of sokovia
bucky catches up to zemo there however
and pulls a handgun on it seemingly
planning to kill him where he stands
the viewers and zemo learn however that
the gun is empty
nothing more than a distraction so that
dora melange can approach
zemo and take him into their custody
when the dora melange
escort him away zemo is essentially
written out of the story
something worth noting in this scene is
that io mentions
they're going to take zemo to the raft
for those unfamiliar
the raft is an underwater prison for
super criminals that made its
live-action
mcu debut in 2016's captain america
civil war
the same movie that brought zemo to the
screen as well
could zemo's time in the raft lead to
the establishment of the thunderbolts
team of villains
similarly to how it's created in the
comics either way
this is certainly not the last time
we'll see zemo in the mcu
a major point of truth is sam's quest to
understand the legacy behind captain
america's
shield for better or worse educating
himself completely
isn't possible without speaking to
isaiah bradley
a black super soldier whom the u.s
government unceremoniously wiped from
the history books
he tells sam all about the atrocities
visited upon him
including the government's penchant or
experimenting on him without his consent
while he was imprisoned for rescuing his
fellow black super soldiers from an
enemy prisoner of war camp
a twisted echo of steve rogers own
heroics and captain america
the first avenger isaiah even refers to
the real-life
red tails also known as the tuskegee
airmen
when he tells sam his story isaiah being
involuntarily subjected to torturous
experimentation
reflects that of the tragic real-life
story of the tuskegee experiment
in which black men were experimented on
by the u.s government
without their consent or knowledge this
chat seemingly presents
sam with only one choice leave captain
america's shield behind
and let it lose its luster as a relic of
american
greatness however it seems clear by the
end of the episode
that sam instead decides to reclaim the
shield for his own
and stand as the black captain america
that isaiah deserved to become
and be remembered as an extremely small
amount of time and truth
is dedicated to catching up with sharon
carter and her shadowy
exploits back in madrid she's appeared a
handful of times in the series so far
shown as having redefined herself as a
successful
illicit art mogul with plenty of wealth
and power
leading many to wonder what her life
post-captain america civil war has
actually been like
sharon's presence this week raises even
more questions
particularly because she apparently
conducts a phone conversation
with mcu villain batch rock the leaper
about working on another job for her for
double the pay
toward the end of the episode batrock
appears with a suitcase full of supplies
for carly morgendale and the flag
smashers
he notes that he doesn't care about
their cause and only wants to kill the
falcon
causing viewers everywhere to scratch
their heads if sharon
is really sam's friend why would she
align herself with someone who wants to
kill him
also was she the one behind batch rock's
heist in the falcon in the winter
soldiers premiere
episode this whole situation lends
itself to the theory that sharon carter
is secretly the power broker suggesting
that she's using
batch rock as a way to get close to
carly in hopes of securing her revenge
for her theft of the super soldier serum
then again
as a former agent of shield carter may
still somehow be conducting some double
secret
espionage that we have yet to fully
understand
with carly hiding out and john walker a
relative non-factor for the bulk of the
episode
sam finally heads back to his family
home in louisiana
he bans the whole community together to
help repair his family's fishing mode
that includes bucky who shows up to give
sam a suitcase from wakanda
and flirt a bit with sam's sister sarah
after spending the night and putting the
finishing touches on the boat the next
morning
sam and bucky start working with the
captain america shield a bit
and share a nice conversation about what
it and they stand for for
bucky this scene reinforces the concern
that he's still not so far removed from
his winter soldier persona
the nightmares persist and as sam notes
he's constantly looking for someone or
something to tell him his goals and
worth as a person
their conversation heavily implies that
steve rogers may have indeed died
leaving bucky as his own man free to
start over in the modern world
as for sam this conversation with bucky
shows that he finally has a better
understanding of what the shield
represents
and how to wield it properly sam doesn't
want to just be the next captain america
he wants to redefine what it means to
carry that title
the two-part ways shortly after their
talk and after agreeing that they're
just
co-workers and a couple of guys and not
really a legitimate team
something tells us that the series final
episode may still prove those assertions
wrong
truth is fairly light when it comes to
showing the flag smashers
and carly morgenthau but it wasn't for
nothing it's mentioned in the middle of
the episode that they are preparing to
mobilize and execute their grand plan
something we begin to see by the
installment's closing scenes
the global repatriation council is
preparing to vote on the patch act
a piece of legislation that would deport
more than 20 million
immigrants and displaced people back to
their home countries
considering their anti-nationalist
message the flag smashers are against
the idea entirely
and are prepared to act to oppose it as
the grc's leaders give their final
statements on the vote
the lights cut to black and the flag
smashers who have just met with batch
rock
and taken advantage of his cache of
weapons move in
what their actual plans might be aren't
made clear though
since the episode quickly moves from
this scene to one of sam wilson at home
sam puts the box bucky gave him earlier
on his bed
and finally opens it growing wide-eyed
and taking a deep breath
before the credits roll considering sam
left his broken wings behind
for potential falcon 2.0 joaquin
torres the wakandan crate more than
likely contains a vibranium-powered set
of wings for the new new captain america
the falcon and the winter soldier will
debut its final episode next week
and we can only hope that marvel studios
will wrap up
every loose threat no matter what though
we can count on the show closing in
similar fashion to how it opened
with plenty of action drama and maybe
even more hints toward the future
trajectory of the mcu
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the falcon and the winter soldier are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one